voilà madame la ministre vous proposons
de commencer cette cette audition madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues membres de la commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique donc nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui les travaux de
la commission d'enquête que nous avons
débuté la semaine dernière avec
l'audition de deux ministres François de
Rugy et Ségolène Royal et dans ce compte
dans ce cadre nous commençons cet
après-midi qui va être longue avec vous
puisque nous allons accueillir
5 pas moins de 5 ministres qui ont été
en charge ou de la transition écologique
l'habitat durable ou des politiques du
logement donc vous avez été élu en 2012
puis nommé membre du gouvernement en
qualité de ministre de l'Égalité des
territoires et du logement de plein
exercice pendant près de deux ans après
2017 vous avez travaillé pour une
entreprise de serveurs
puis vous avez pris depuis l'été 2018 la
direction de
l'ongsfam sans France je précise que
c'est aujourd'hui en votre qualité
d'ancienne ministre que nous vous
recevons votre expérience
gouvernementale a notamment été marquée
par la préparation et le vote de Dallois
auquel votre nom reste associé la loi
Duflot 1 relative à la mobilisation du
foncier public en faveur du logement et
au renforcement des obligations de
production de logements social et la loi
Duflot 2 pour l'accès au logement et un
urbanisme rénové plus connu sous le nom
de loi allure c'est donc une période
particulièrement importante pour la
politique de logement ce qui concerne
évidemment directement notre sujet les
objectifs de rénovation énergétique que
nous nous étions fixés notamment la
rénovation de 500 000 logements par an
ne sont pas
alors que le bâtiment demeure un secteur
particulièrement énergivore et émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre la rénovation
énergétique reste également une question
sociale puisque de trop nombreux
Français sont en situation de précarité
énergétique madame la ministre la
Commission souhaite savoir le bilan que
vous tirez de votre passage au
gouvernement quels sont en matière de
rénovation énergétique vos principaux
motifs de satisfaction et qu'elles sont
au contraire vos regrets les sujets sur
lesquels vous auriez souhaité aller plus
loin dans ce cas quelles ont été les
obstacles que vous avez pu rencontrer et
quel verrou avez-vous vu avez-vous
identifié est-ce qu'un ministre de plein
exercice a été un atout ou à présenter
au contraire des difficultés pour la
coordination avec le ministre chargé de
l'écologie et de l'énergie
je voudrais également vous inviter à
nous donner votre analyse des raisons
pour lesquelles les objectifs visés ne
sont toujours pas atteints quel jugement
portez-vous sur la politique menée en
matière de rénovation énergétique depuis
votre départ du gouvernement la
rénovation énergétique bute-t-elle sur
des questions de financement de
règlementation de méthode
d'inconstances ou sur une prise de
conscience insuffisante de tous ces
enjeux avant de vous laisser la parole
pour un propos introductif d'une
quinzaine de minutes il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu qui sera
publié je dois également vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête serait passible des
peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc madame la ministre à prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité a levé la main droite et à dire
je le jure
je vous en remercie et je vous laisse la
parole après votre prise de parole le
rapporteur bien sûr aura des questions
également à vous poser ainsi que
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
d'enquête qui sont présents aujourd'hui
dans cette salle je vous laisse la
parole merci beaucoup
rappeler mon parcours il se trouve donc
j'étais ministre il y a plus de 10 ans
désormais et que j'ai arrêté toute
activité politique depuis 2017 depuis
juin 2017 donc vous m'avez conduite à me
replonger dans quelques archives mais je
voudrais dire ici que si je fais
quelques approximations notamment sur le
plan des chiffres je m'en excuse bien
volonté dont vous je j'ai juré
solennellement et ce serait donc
uniquement des erreurs de date ou des
erreurs de mémoire
d'autant que l'intégralité de mes
archives y compris nos archives
personnelles sont restés et sont à
disposition ministère donc qui elles
sont parfaitement consultables je
voulais commencer par vous raconter une
anecdote qui je pense est assez
illustratif du sujet sur lequel vous
travaillez
j'ai donc été nommé ministre en 2012
juste après l'élection de François
Hollande et quelques semaines après le
nouveau Président je crois que c'était
son titre du programme investissement
d'avenir tout fraîchement nommé Louis
Gallois demande à me rencontrer
évidemment j'accepte et nous avons un
échange sur la fonction des programmes
investissement d'avenir si vous vous
souvenez c'est un programme lancé par
Nicolas Sarkozy après la crise de 2008
un programme de relance massive et une
partie de ce programme devait être
consacrée à la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments le nouveau président me dit
donc que il y avait un budget de 500
millions d'euros consacré à la
rénovation thermique des
habitations des plus démunis et que
malencontreusement ce programme faisait
l'objet d'une sous consommation massive
puisque 5 millions seulement avait été
engagés et que donc il souhaitait
m'informer que
dans le cadre de leur réflexion il
souhaitait réattribuer le reliquat soit
49 millions d'euros à Airbus vous
imaginez que la toute nouvelle ministre
du Logement qui plus est écologiste a eu
un petit moment de fraîcheur à l'annonce
de cette disposition et je vais
expliquer que ça allait pas être
possible que je pensais que c'était une
erreur mais que quand même il y avait un
sujet sur cette sous-consommation après
enquête et je résume à gros trait la
sous-consommation s'expliquait assez
naturellement puisque les publics
visaient par ce programme devait
répondre au plafond plaiste à dire
environ 60% du SMIC là encore je vous
dis de mémoire donc on va dire donc des
plafonds assez bas mais pour des
montants de travaux très importants de
lors d'une trentaine de milliers d'euros
donc on comprend très volo très
rapidement que engager des travaux de
plus de 30000 euros quand on a comme
revenu moins de 60% du SMIC forcément
c'est très compliqué
à la suite de ça j'ai organisé une
rencontre avec l'ensemble des
intervenants dans ce domaine là dont les
régions qui étaient mobilisées assez
largement je rappelle qu'à l'époque
c'était avant la réforme il y avait
beaucoup plus de régions qu'aujourd'hui
pour un échange assez intéressant dans
lequel autour de la table chaque
représentante en du monde HLM que de
l'Association des régions de France que
de l'ensemble des élus que
les responsables de l'ADEME de la NA
tout le monde explique que tout va
parfaitement bien que tout est
parfaitement en ordre et chacun déroule
on va dire le grand talent avec lequel
ils ont mis en oeuvre des politiques je
leur explique qu'il y a quand même un
sujet c'est que tout semble parfait mais
que visiblement ça marche pas c'est pour
résumer ce qu'il y a été à le guide de
mon action comme ministre pendant ces
deux années ce qui a fait l'objet donc
d'une première annonce si je ne me
trompe pas en janvier 2013 de ce que
devait être une évolution de des
manières d'intervenir en matière de
rénovation thermique c'est-à-dire non
seulement de mobiliser de l'argent mais
surtout de simplifier et à cet instant
je veux dire que je crois qu'un des
principaux handicaps et donc je vais
donc devancer votre votre question c'est
le morcellement des acteurs en charge du
dossier ça c'est le premier point c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de d'initiatives qui
sont bonnes mais il y a un morcellement
très grand et puis il y a surtout une
capacité de la part de certains acteurs
privés à utiliser de manière très
opportuniste des dispositifs qui en
eux-mêmes notamment les crédits d'impôts
peuvent être intéressant mais qui ont
parfois fait l'objet d'utilisation
complètement détournée ce qui a conduit
le législateur notamment au moment de
l'examen des lois de finances à chaque
fois à être très prudent puisque chaque
parlementaire avait des témoignages
d'abus qui s'appuyait sur des
démarchages parfois un peu agressifs de
personnes dont on isolait dont on change
les fenêtres alors que le toit n'était
pas isolé par exemple ce qui est sur un
plan énergétique parfaitement absurde
donc ce morcellement plus des
dispositifs conçus de manière
je sais pas quel est le bon adjectif
mais
désordonné peut-être qui chacun prit
individuellement pouvait avoir du sens
mais qui n'était pas coordonnées
conduisait aux résultats qu'on connaît
et qu'on connaît d'ailleurs pour une
part toujours c'est à dire
une grande limite dans la capacité à
mettre en œuvre un programme de
rénovation thermique
j'ai donc fini par obtenir une sorte de
pacte politique avec le Premier ministre
qui était et donc je réponds aussi la
part anticipation à votre question
est-ce que c'était un outil d'être
ministre de plein exercice oui d'être
ministre de plein exercice et oui
d'avoir du poids politique j'avais du
poids politique pour deux raisons je
représentais le seul parti partenaire
presque de la coalition politique qui
existait alors et par ailleurs j'avais
un entraînement particulier qui est que
vous avez pas rappelé que j'étais
secrétaire national du parti écologiste
pendant six ans ce qui je pense est fait
partie des meilleurs écoles de
l'entraînement au rapport de force que
qui puisse exister sur le marché de la
politique et que je conseille à tout le
monde mais si j'en crois les autres
personnes que vous allez auditionner
cette école a formé un panel politique
qui maintenant va sur l'ensemble du
spectre politique français quasiment
sans exclusion donc je crois que c'est
une bonne école donc je le dis un mini
de plein exercice une capacité au
rapport de politique au rapport de force
politique et la possibilité obtenir des
arbitrages tant termorganisationnel
qu'en termes financier parce que et ce
sera la clé du dispositif et l'histoire
assez rapide puisque dès 2014 les choses
se sont gâtées à montrer que en mettant
en cohérence le dispositif en abondant
de manière extrêmement significative les
fonds de la NA ça avait très bien
fonctionné ça a très bien fonctionné
pendant très peu de temps puisque comme
et donc là je tiens à le dire de manière
la plus ferme qui soit entre les
annonces financières et la réalité des
crédits notamment du fait des gels qui
sont opérés dès l'été souvent par Bercy
vous avez des situations de crispation
et en regardant mes archives j'ai
retrouvé le nombre de questions y
compris d'ailleurs de vos collègues
sénateurs de question écrite ou de
questions orales de chaque sénateur qui
interroge sur son territoire et sur son
département le fait que il y avait plein
de dossiers en attente et en souffrance
dans les tiroirs de Lana parce qu'il y
avait simplement plus donc l'année 2014
a été très marquante donc pour tout dire
le pacte que j'avais avec le Premier
ministre était simple c'était un montant
très important et si ça marchait
d'abonder ce montant il se trouve que
j'ai quitté le gouvernement pour des
raisons qui n'ont pas avoir avec le
programme de rénovation énergétique mais
d'autres raisons politiques que cet
argent a été très bien dépensé très vite
dépensé beaucoup plus vite que ce qui
était prévu et que au lieu d'être abondé
mais le changement de Premier ministre
est donc obligé il a été il n'a pas fait
l'objet d'abondement et ça a été très
bien dit d'ailleurs notamment par
Valérie Letard qui a été présidente de
Lana et qui connaît parfaitement le
sujet c'est que la restriction de ces
crédits doublés du fait de la baisse
après le brexit du prix du carbone qui a
fait aussi baisser les ressources de
Lana et malgré un amendement pris de 50
millions si je me trompe pas sur le
budget
de ce qui devait s'appeler déjà Action
Logement ou je ne sais pas encore enfin
des crédits de feu en pour cent
logements
des crédit de la nana n'était pas
suffisant pour suivre les engagements
qui avaient été pris
l'autre élément qui avait rendu la chose
très facilitatrice était le fait de
créer un guichet unique par le biais
d'un numéro de téléphone et d'obliger
l'ensemble des acteurs toutes les
collectivités locales et les différents
acteurs à
donner leurs données et renvoyer
l'ensemble des interlocuteurs et
notamment des personnes physiques vers
un seul guichet donc oui bien sûr cette
ce morcellement et la complexité rend
extrêmement périlleux le montage de ses
dossiers pour moi il y a pas besoin
d'aller chercher plus loin nous
disposons des professionnels et des
professionnels formés nous disposons
aussi de leurs capacité à monter en
charge si c'était nécessaire mais il y a
un vrai sujet d'effet de levier qui est
celui permis par la mobilisation
d'argent public lequel argent public est
extrêmement bien utilisé à deux titres
alors nous faisons peu ce genre d'études
en France mais l'étude dont je vous
parle est assez ancienne mais les
Britanniques qui évaluaient les
économies en matière de financement de
l'assurance maladie enfin l'équivalent
de l'Assurance Maladie de
l'investissement dans la rénovation
thermique notamment pour ce qui est des
personnes âgées parce qu'on sait très
bien que la précarité énergétique
au-delà des conséquences sociales de
confort à des conséquences sur la santé
significatif et que donc c'est
investissement peut être compensé par
des économies alors je sais qu'on fait
peu ses études et il se trouve que
depuis presque 5 ans maintenant je
travaille dans une organisation qui a
une culture anglo-saxonne donc ça ne
choque moins que ça pourrait choquer des
Français mais sur le bon usage de
l'argent public de voir effectivement ce
que ça peut coûter comme argent mais ce
que ça économise au-delà de l'aspect
moral et satisfaisant d'avancer vers
davantage de justice sociale c'est très
intéressant l'autre élément c'est que
c'est aussi un investissement d'argent
public très rentable puisque les travaux
de rénovation thermique sont une
activité parfaitement
non délocalisable et qui fourni de
l'emploi local donc je ne saurais pas
évalué et je ne sais pas s'il existe des
études publiées sur l'impact d'un euro
d'argent public investi dans la
rénovation thermique en création de
richesse et en diminution du chômage
mais je suis sûr qu'elle serait forte
intéressante à conduire parce qu'elles
sont à mon avis très marquantes
autre élément très important je crois le
recul qui a été pris dans
l'investissement des collectivités
locales parce que évidemment la question
des bâtiments et des logements est
importante mais la question du tertiaire
et notamment des bâtiments publics dans
le respect du patrimoine et dans le
respect des prérogatives des architectes
des bâtiments de France mais néanmoins
de façon très volontariste et pour moi
aussi un élément clé de de levier très
utile et qui a été sous-utilisé là aussi
j'ai mémoire d'une réunion de discussion
extrêmement vive sur l'investissement de
la Caisse des Dépôts possibles pour
aider une collectivités locales à
conduire une vraie politique
d'économie d'énergie un peu plus large
mais aussi de rénovation de leur
patrimoine il faut savoir que beaucoup
de collectivités locales possèdent des
bâtiments construits dans la pire
période la pire période n'étant pas
celle qui est autour de nous mais les
années 70-80 qui ont conduit à produire
j'ai fâché les années 70 et 80
qui ont conduit à une production de
consommateur
consommateur d'énergie parfois y compris
avec des systèmes de chauffage qui sont
des systèmes de chauffage eux aussi très
très énergivores donc la conjonction de
ces deux phénomènes mon point de vue
était un frein important pourquoi j'en
tire une expérience
nuancée d'abord parce que ça s'est
arrêté mais parce que ça a marché c'est
à dire que pendant une cour période il y
a eu vraiment un effet considérable au
sein de Lana alors je pense que vous
pourriez avec intérêt
convié les personnes de Lana qui était
présente à cette époque parce qu'elles
en ont un souvenir sans doute plus
précis que le mien mais si je retrouve
les chiffres les le bilan qui avait été
tiré au bout d'un an était très très
positif parce qu'il y avait une
appétence forte et je pense que en le
disant presque 10 ans après
malheureusement il y aura une appétence
encore beaucoup plus importante
cette rénovation thermique notamment des
bâtiments des particuliers n'est pas
possible sans l'effet de levier de la du
financement public je le crois d'abord à
ce qu'il est un outil de motivation
ensuite parce que il y a un écart entre
le taux d'investissement nécessaire et
le taux de rentabilité qui peut être
beaucoup trop long pour un certain
nombre de personnes physiques ça n'est
pas le cas je le dis pour les personnes
morales que ce soit les entreprises ou
la question du tertiaire ou les
collectivités locales mais pour les
propriétaires personnes physiques c'est
plus compliqué je pense qu'il y a deux
angles morts
le premier angle mort c'est celui des
propriétaires bailleurs
le dispositif qui permet de contribuer
aux travaux d'économie d'énergie en
échange de du conventionnement Anaï est
un bon dispositif de mon point de vue
mais il serait beaucoup plus efficace
s'il était plus contraignant alors les
avancées législatives vont sans doute le
permettre mais je crains un angle mort
actuel
et là je fais quoi un débat qui était un
débat vif à l'époque ce débat a été
résolu entre les organisations de
protection de l'environnement qui
étaient très volontariste sur l'éviction
des passoires thermiques de
l'autorisation de location enfin de les
faire rentrer dans le décret d'essence
qui va arriver avec les logements de
type G mais avec du coup un risque et je
le vois là je puisque votre commission
travaille aujourd'hui je me permets
cette petite alerte c'est à dire que la
vente massive de logement
qui sont plus possibles d'être loués et
qui vont être rachetés uniquement par
des gens qui auront les moyens de
pouvoir investir pour faire ces travaux
pour relouer donc pas forcément à un
tarif très intéressant et avec une
concentration du patrimoine locatif qui
est déjà très identifié qui a été très
identifié par l'INSEE et qui à mon avis
est un problème qui dépasse le problème
de la rénovation énergétique mais je
pense qu'en matière de logement et j'y
reviendrai avoir une vision globale des
enjeux et pas de manière sectorisée
entre le prix des loyers le prix du
foncier
la consommation thermique des bâtiments
me paraît être absolument nécessaire
puisque quand on parle de logement on
touche à un sujet qui relève des besoins
fondamentaux de l'être humain comme
boire ou manger on a besoin d'un abri je
crois que
l'intervention de la puissance publique
sur ces sujets et absolument essentiel
dernier élément que je voulais apporter
à votre réflexion
les embarder divers et variés l'absence
de Constance
alors je crois que les objectifs sont
toujours annoncés en étant les mêmes
mais qui sont jamais tenus et donc je
trouve ça très intéressant que vous vous
posiez la question de savoir pourquoi
ils sont pas tenus ils sont pas tenus là
en l'occurrence les objectifs qu'ils
avaient que j'avais annoncé en tant que
ministre ils ont pas été tenus parce que
l'amendement qui avait été promis entre
guillemets par le Premier ministre s'il
dispositif fonctionnel n'a pas été mise
en oeuvre et donc il y a de fait une
restriction et quand vous aboutissez je
pense que ces embarder sont aussi
naturarénées durablement parce que les
gens pensent que ça va marcher plus que
ça va pas marcher et comme ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie de monter un dossier
et beaucoup de complexité vous avez une
perte en ligne qui est considérable et
au fil des années un épuisement des
acteurs et ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose de nouveau je pense qu'il peut y
avoir un épuisement des acteurs de tous
ceux qui travaillent dans ce domaine du
fait de cette complexité pour s'attaquer
à ce sujet je suis maintenant assez
convaincue qu'il est absolument
nécessaire d'avoir un service public de
la rénovation énergétique
qui est capable d'être un guichet unique
notamment des différents financements
possibles par les différentes
collectivités locales mais aussi et j'y
tiens là de fournir une expertise en
matière
énergétique qui soit une expertise
honnête
bien sûr si vous
n'avez pas
une vraie objectivité sur la
priorisation des travaux effectués dans
un logement vous pouvez aboutir à des
aberrations et une dépense d'argent qui
n'aura pas d'effet sur les économies
d'énergie et ça c'est donc quel a été la
réponse du législateur de supprimer tout
un tas de crédits d'impôts ce qui était
positif dans un sens à éviter des abus
négatifs dans un autre parce que ça
pouvait être parfaitement utile donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait une vision
beaucoup plus
partagée d'un vrai diagnostic et d'une
priorisation des travaux parce que et là
aussi donc une pierre dans le jardin des
écologistes
mais débats de ministres ont été
difficiles avec certaines associations
écologistes qui considéraient que or une
rénovation globale qui aboutissait à un
niveau Bâtiment Basse Consommation
point de salut au sens où de gagner
quelques
pas étaient pas suffisant j'entends sur
un plan théorique je l'entends bien mais
pour certains c'était en fait le
résultat c'était rien
l'objection justifiée était dire que
certains travaux qui apparaissaient
comme des travaux de rénovation
énergétique j'ai donné tout à l'heure
cet exemple des fenêtres quand le toit
est pas isolé c'était absurde c'est vrai
c'est pour ça que je pense que le
diagnostic énergétique préalable fait de
manière objective et sans que ce soit
ensuite celui qui a intérêt à faire les
travaux qui fassent ce diagnostic et à
mon avis absolument décisif donc et je
fais le lien avec la loi alur beaucoup
ont reproché
les abus de diagnostic préalable aux
ventes de logement je pense que si ils
sont bien faits c'est au contraire très
utile parce que avant
oui oui bien sûr je pense que avant
pardon
excusez-moi
on faisait
acquérir des biens à des personnes qui
passeront des comptes au bout de
quelques mois qu'en fait elle pouvait
tout simplement pas payer le chauffage
de leur de leur habitation qui se
retrouvait surendettée des dans les
semaines ou les mois qui suivaient leur
acquisition en n'ayant pas eu
connaissance du tout de l'ensemble de
ces éléments et que quand vous engagez à
acheter un bien il y a évidemment le
coup du prêt mais il y a bien d'autres
dépenses qui n'étaient pas du tout
évaluées je le rappelle avant la loi
alur donc au titre des fiertés et je le
dis de manière très très modeste parce
que c'est recommandations n'étaient pas
ne sont pas sorties de de mon cerveau
mettez l'objet j'avais fait l'objet de
rapport parlementaire et de proposition
d'un certain nombre de parlementaires
tant à l'Assemblée qu'au Sénat je pense
que c'est ce sont de bonnes avancées
mais que maintenant il faut aller un pas
plus loin et je pense que or ce guichet
unique or cette interlocuteur simple on
n'arrivera pas à massifier les objectifs
de rénovation thermique le deuxième
élément c'est un élément de financière
donc je sais que c'est plus à la mode
les lois de programmation
sauf quand elles sont dans un cas de
militaire mais je pense que si on veut
lancer des grands travaux qui perdent
nous permettent à la fois à la
transition énergétique et de essayer de
tenir notre
SNBC mais aussi de pouvoir se préparer à
l'adaptation nécessaire à laquelle nous
allons devoir faire face du fait du
changement climatique il faut absolument
une loi de programmation qui sécurise
pour l'ensemble des acteurs comme pour
les particuliers
une trajectoire dans la durée je suis
absolument résolue parce que l'échec de
ce qui a été annoncé par la ministre
Cécile Duflot en 2013 il est écrit dans
une réponse à une question
au Sénat que je vais vous retrouver qui
dit de manière très claire que les
crédits de la de Lana ont été gelés au
mois de juin de l'année 2014
et que du coup les objectifs qui avaient
été affichés même les dossiers qui
existaient dans les tiroirs de Lana ne
pouvaient pas être mise en oeuvre donc
voilà c'est finalement assez simple ça
semble complexe c'est pas si complexe
mais comme toutes les politiques
d'ampleur je pense qu'elle nécessite
une organisation qui soit simplifiée et
une visibilité dans la durée de la même
manière que quand on investit dans un
grand programme industriel on fait un
scénario d'investissement sur plusieurs
années étonnamment l'État qui
normalement est là pour le restant de
nos jours n'est pas capable de le faire
et je pense que c'est une faute et une
erreur c'est pas tellement le fait de
des ministres qui sont succédés à cette
responsabilité peut-être
alors elle a été elle est elle est
toujours fin alors pour le coup vous
vous êtes dans une politique où tout le
monde est d'accord je pense qu'il y a
des politiques qui peuvent faire des
balles encadrement des loyers on
pourrait avoir un débat sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments tout
le monde est d'accord donc pourquoi une
politique où tout le monde est d'accord
ou tout le monde dit que c'est bien on
n'arrive pas à mettre en œuvre votre
commission intéressante moi je peux vous
le dire parce qu'on tient pas dans la
durée sur l'argent et oui je le dis le
pilotage budgétaire ce qui est ma
surprise moi je ne je n'ai pas j'ai
travaillé uniquement dans le secteur
privé avant de rejoindre
un poste de ministre et
j'ai été très surprise de la dimension
cours thermiste avec laquelle est piloté
le budget d'un grand pays comme la
France et je dois le dire mes
discussions budgétaires avec les
différents ministres du Budget ont
toujours été parfois
désespérante la norme de dépenses
puisque c'est comme ça qui convient de
parler étant la chose la plus stupide
que j'ai connue dans ma vie parce que
quand vous avez vous êtes capable de
prouver qu'un investissement d'un euro
d'argent public peut rapporter 1,3 euros
d'argent public à échéance 5 ans
n'importe quel investisseur n'importe
lequel signe dans la seconde n'importe
lequel sauf l'état sauf l'État et je le
dis les règles budgétaires telles
qu'elles sont mises en oeuvre
aujourd'hui dans la loi de finances me
semble dans un certain nombre de cas
complètement absurde contre-productive
et
finalement assez rageante et le bilan
que je retire sur cette politique là et
assez rageant
vous me permettrez d'avoir la franchise
qui m'était déjà coutumière à l'époque
mais qui s'est enrichi de mon
éloignement de de vos cercles
parlementaires
merci beaucoup madame la ministre déjà
de ses premiers éléments je laisse la
parole à notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
la Ministre déjà pour pour vos propos
qui ont à la fois assez large et qui
balaye bien en fait la problématique est
face à nous qu'effectivement je pense
que c'est vous l'avez bien rappelé une
politique où je pense tout le monde est
d'accord en tout cas sur les objectifs
sur les orientations et peut-être sur la
volonté mais on se confronte
effectivement depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années sur du coup des objectifs qui
sont pas qui sont pas atteints et on
voit bien qu'on piétine en fait avec
avec différents types de d'action et en
tout cas de d'action qui se qui se
renouvelaient en tout cas qui s'empile
parfois donc c'est peut-être moi ma
première question c'est peut-être depuis
on va dire 2012-2013 en tout cas ou
c'est vrai que vous avez été un petit
peu la première en tout cas vraiment
mettre en place et à donner des
orientations sur l'axe de 500 000
logements rénovés sur des éléments comme
sur le je crois que c'était le point de
rénovation thermique mais en tout cas
d'avoir une porte d'entrée qui
permettait vraiment de dire voilà on a
un élément simple à qui s'adresser pour
ensuite avoir de l'ingénierie de
l'accompagnement
donc voilà les premières lignes on va
dire de cette politique de cette
politique publique était était là en
2012-2013 et bien expliqué en fait les
questions à la fois financières et puis
mais ce qu'on peut s'apercevoir jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est que il y a la question
financière qui est une chose mais il y a
aussi des modifications qui ont été
rajoutées et c'est ce qu'on peut voir un
petit peu quand même sur un peu une
usine à gaz qui s'est mis en place quoi
parce que on a modifié on a remodifié on
s'est appuyé parfois sur les territoires
après on a arrêté on a enfin voilà je
pense qu'il y a donc j'aurais bien aimé
avoir vous votre vision en fait depuis
2013 jusqu'à aujourd'hui notamment à
travers le crédit d'impôt qui est passé
prime rénov enfin voilà c'est ces types
de modifications qui ont pu apparaître
et comment vous les percevez et est-ce
que pour vous ça voilà ça vous paraît
justement aussi une des problématiques
j'avais une autre une autre question
plus précise il me semble que c'était
vous qui avez mis en place ou en tout
cas il y avait une réflexion sur un
passeport de la rénovation thermique et
que je trouvais assez intéressant c'est
à dire qu'il y avait un
document en tout cas qui permettait de
se dire voilà sur tel logement jusqu'où
on peut aller pour aller jusqu'à un
bâtiment BBC et puis après il y a les
étapes quoi et on sait que du coup on
peut cette première étape la deuxième et
que tout ne se fait pas forcément en
même temps je trouve que c'était quelque
chose d'assez pertinent qu'on a un peu
perdu de vue depuis fin parce que
notamment avec la prime rénov on
s'aperçoit dans le bilan qui peut en
être fait que on se retrouve avec un
seul élément qui qui est financé et
puissant cohérence en tout cas avec le
avec le reste et voilà ma question était
justement pourquoi ce cet aspect là qui
est peut-être on en avait pas dans la
loi
dans la loi climat qui était peut-être
un carnet de santé du bâtiment en tout
cas qui permettait justement d'avoir ce
suivi là pourquoi justement ça a pas ça
a pas pris en tout cas il y a pas eu ce
suivi ce suivi là
et puis peut-être pour finir et pour
laisser la place à mes collègues sur les
sur les questions
on a reçu
Ségolène Roy François de Rugy juste
avant c'était nos premières nos
premières auditions et peut-être le lien
entre les ministères de l'écologie et
ministère du Logement quoi savoir en
fait vous est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui qui vous a posé problème en tout cas
dans les orientations qui pouvaient être
données parce que c'est vrai que
notamment sur la question de la
résorption des des passoires thermiques
par exemple sur le fait de dire on met
plus à la location des des bâtiments
classés classés derrière on sait très
bien que bah oui mais ça risque de
fermer un certain nombre de logements et
donc du coup entre les deux ministères
parfois des orientations qui peuvent
être assez assez contradictoires en tout
cas avec des enjeux qui peuvent être
différents est-ce que ça c'est quelque
chose aussi que vous avez ressenti en
tout cas voilà je m'arrêterai là puis
s'il y a d'autres voilà permettra tout
le monde de pouvoir poser des questions
merci alors vous laisserez répondre à
monsieur le rapporteur et après mes
collègues poseront d'autres questions
alors déjà je pense qu'il y a un piège
dans lequel sont obligés de tomber les
ministres c'est celui qu'on appelle les
annonces il faut qu'un ministre fasse
des annonces tenir une politique initiée
par d'autres et juste dire bah ça marche
pas mal on va continuer c'est quasi
impossible surtout quand il y a un
changement de majorité donc ça c'est un
problème c'est pour ça que je pense que
peut-être une loi de programmation sur
certains sujets moi je serais maintenant
sur une sorte de d'accord assez général
la loi allure avait été votée par très
largement y compris par des groupes qui
n'étaient pas dans la majorité avec des
débats et moi je j'ai beaucoup de goût
et rétrospectivement je continue le
penser et l'actualité me fait mis référé
encore davantage pour un vrai travail
parlementaire notamment sur des
questions qui touchent j'allais presque
dire de manière transpartisane parce que
n'importe quel élu locaux c'est très
bien que la question du logement se
résout pas par des coups de menton on
peut avoir des divergences sur certains
sujets mais au fil de du temps on arrive
à des convergences et je le dis souvent
souriant la garantie universelle des
loyers qui ne figure plus dans la loi
puisqu'elle a été abrogée lors de la loi
Elan c'est une idée qui m'a été donnée
par Jean-Louis Borloo en me disant que
ce qui était là jli et la grèl qui
d'ailleurs a été transformée en visage
ne marchait pas ce qui est le cas il
faudrait une garantie universelle et je
pense qu'on y reviendra que c'est
l'histoire de la vie du logement mais ça
n'était pas une idée que j'ai inventé
c'était une idée réfléchie de
prédécesseur donc évidemment il faut
dire que ça s'appelle plus habiter mieux
que ça s'appelle je sais pas comment que
ça voilà pour faire une grande annonce
pour avoir une dépêche AFP et de la même
manière il peut y avoir une petite
comment dire Bizzbee entre les ministres
pour dire qui est-ce qui va faire
l'annonce sur le sujet moi j'ai aucun
souvenir de tension et je le dis au
contraire d'ailleurs ça peut se voir et
j'ai sous les yeux le bilan le premier
bilan qui avait été fait en mars 2014
donc le 6 mars 2014 qui était un bilan
conjoint de Philippe Martin alors
ministère ministre de l'écologie et de
de Cécile Duflot ministre du logement
sans aucune tension contraire et donc
d'ailleurs j'ai les chiffres sous les
yeux c'était c'est marrant parce que
c'était plus de 27000 projets ont été
enregistrés par Lana au second semestre
2013 contre moins de 4000 auparavant le
rite des rénovations a été multiplié par
5 avec 1,2 milliards d'euros fait
l'existence d'un numéro de téléphone
unique avait été popularisé avec bien
fonctionné et ça avait bien fonctionné
parce que justement aussi il y avait un
double portage politique au sein du
gouvernement
et donc je crois pour le coup je pense
que et là je le dis de manière
extrêmement détachée les grands moments
d'avancer des lois logement
ont eu lieu quand il y a eu un ministre
de plein exercice qui avait sinon le
l'oreille du du
Premier ministre ou un poids politique
personnel mais en tout cas ça n'a jamais
existé à d'autres moments et je le dis
par exemple dans la loi alur figure des
dispositions qui étaient en souffrance
depuis 25 ans relatif aux droits de vote
en copropriété des choses historiques
qui avaient jamais été à l'agenda du
ministère de la justice puisque c'est
lui qui avait en charge ces questions et
c'est un accord politique avec
Christiane Taubira à l'époque où je lui
avais dit ok laisse-moi m'en occuper et
ça c'était bien passé donc moi je crois
fondamentalement à la politique pour
vous répondre madame la Présidente et
aussi monsieur le rapporteur je crois à
l'utilité des ministres quand ils ont
quand ils sont pas uniquement des
porte-voix des éléments de langage quand
ils sont capables d'une certaine
autonomie quand ils ont un cabinet
suffisamment robuste pour que des
habitudes de toujours de
l'administration puissent puissent être
dépassés je cette expérience
ministérielle et un certain nombre
d'avancés me font laisser partir avec la
conviction profonde de l'efficacité de
la politique donc non il n'y a pas de
difficulté à ce qui est de ministère au
contraire et je vais vous dire le
l'espace de travail du ministre de
l'écologie aujourd'hui depuis que
l'énergie a été intégrée à ce ministère
et suffisamment vaste pour qu'il soit
très
occupé par d'autres sujets et uniquement
d'avoir une
comment dire un troupeau de secrétaire
d'État dont on a pris le directeur de
cabinet dans son propre cabinet je suis
pas sûr du tout que ce soit très utile
je en tout cas le et je pense qu'en
revanche si les gens sont capables de
travailler en bonne intelligence ça peut
être beaucoup plus efficace voilà et en
tout cas cette expérience l'a montré
j'ai pas eu difficulté à travailler avec
mon collègue Philippe Martin mais pas eu
difficulté pour travailler avec Delphine
bateau sur ses questions là
même si nous étions toutes les deux des
personnalités assez fortes et assez
autonome si vous êtes justement capable
de passer des accords politiques avec
des gens qui sont solides vous avez une
efficacité dans le dans le fait de
délivrer ces politiques publiques donc
c'est ça qui explique le ma prime rénov
et surtout je vais le dire quand on fait
diminuer des politiques on essaye de les
rhabiller et on justifie que bah on met
fin au guichet unique parce que ça
donnera plus de souplesse ou de
réactivité enfin l'argumentaire est
celui-là dans l'histoire récente
des politiques de rénovation thermique
il y a eu ces six mois là où on avait un
milliard de d'euros un seul numéro de
téléphone et Lana qui en avait dit vous
avez le lead et ça a marché voilà donc
je dis pas et je le dis de façon très
libre ça fait 10 ans ça a pas duré
longtemps peut-être que si j'étais resté
j'aurais pu permettre que ça tienne mais
en tout cas à ce moment-là ça a marché
donc est-ce que c'est la bonne méthode
oui le passeport bien sûr que c'est la
même chose que le fond travaux en fait
quand vous êtes sur les questions de
logement que ce soit en matière de
politique publique comme en matière de
gestion des travaux il y a la question
du temps rien ne se fait de manière
instantanée vous pouvez changer les
règles du chômage quasiment du jour au
lendemain quand vous lancez un chantier
de rénovation d'une copropriété entre le
moment où vous faites la première âgée
de copro qui va réfléchir à faire un
diagnostic et le moment où vous avez
terminé les travaux allez si on est
super efficace il va se passer deux ans
donc forcément vous avez cette question
du management du temps et c'est pour ça
que j'insiste beaucoup je pense que si
dans vos travaux vous pouvez mettre en
lumière ça cette question de la durée
c'est une politique publique qui sans
durer sans constance ne peut pas
fonctionner et quand elle est l'otage
des annonces ou du rhabillage de
restrictions budgétaire par un nouveau
nom et une micro campagne de pub pardon
pour la franchise de mes propos mais
c'est évident que ça peut pas marcher
voilà
ensuite
votre autre question c'était sur les
travaux uniques et donc j'entends dans
votre voix un discours qui est souvent
porté par les écologistes sur la vision
globale c'est tout à fait vrai mais
c'est pour ça qu'il y avait cette idée
de passeport c'est parce qu'il faut dire
aux questions fait pas tout d'un seul
coup par quoi il vaut mieux commencer et
pour certaines maisons c'est isolé le
toit pour d'autres c'est changer la
porte d'entrée sous lequel il y a un
jour de 3 cm donc en fait il y a pas de
règle c'est l'autre élément il faut de
la durée de la constance mais il faut
aussi une expertise pour s'adapter à
chaque bâtiment
certains bâtiments ont besoin d'une
isolation par extérieur pour d'autres
c'est absurde ça a un impact et ça je
pense que il faut aussi réfléchir il y a
une difficulté sur l'isolation par
l'intérieur sur la diminution du nombre
de mètres carrés et donc la diminution
de la valeur du patrimoine puisque la
valeur des logements et très liée au
diagnostic et au mètre carré loi caresse
et peut-être il faudrait faire une sorte
de pondération entre la qualité
énergétique du bâtiment et le nombre de
mètres carrés je sais pas de quelle
manière mais je pense qu'il y a une
piste à réfléchir
et enfin je suis pas sûr d'avoir répondu
à toutes vos questions sur le rapporteur
qui va un petit peu dans le sens de on
voit qu'à cette nécessité
d'accompagnement et du coup la place des
territoires quoi de se dire comment
alors ça c'est l'autre ce sujet de la
même manière localement enfin voilà
chaque collectivité locale veut avoir sa
politique alors à l'époque en plus
c'était les régions il y avait beaucoup
d'écologistes dans les régions à cette
époque là donc chacun avait inventé son
truc qui n'était pas tous les mêmes nos
territoires en territoire ce qui est
légitime mais ce qui rend les choses
encore plus complexes à appréhender
notamment parce que vous pouvez pas
faire une grande campagne nationale pour
dire voilà si vous gagnez moins de temps
vous pouvez faire des travaux de temps
et avoir une subvention de temps en gros
c'est les gens ont besoin de de d'avoir
cette visibilité et là ça rend les
choses impossibles c'est pour ça que la
question la question du du guichet
unique avec des spécialistes avec des
gens qui sont capables de monter les
dossiers de subvention quand ils sont
multiples c'est très important c'est
bien qu'il y a des initiatives locales
mais je pense que une politique est
notamment parce que en fait vous n'avez
pas les mêmes besoins et moi qui suis
très très attachée à une solidarité
territoriale je pense qu'en revanche
vous n'avez pas les mêmes besoins en
matière de rénovation thermique quand
vous êtes à Nice et quand vous êtes à
Béthune
en termes d'humidité en terme de prise
en compte du confort d'été il y a des
sujets qui sont des sujets différents
donc c'est vrai que des règles univoques
du nord au sud du territoire c'est ça
peut être problématique c'est pour ça
que je parle de ce service public de la
rénovation qui pourrait s'appuyer sur
des dispositifs existants mais ça veut
dire de la même manière si je peux
prendre un exemple la loi allure a mis
en oeuvre l'existence des observatoires
des loyers une même méthodologie mais
des initiatives différentes mais une
même méthodologie pour pouvoir comparer
des données du nord au sud et sur
l'ensemble des territoires ce qui
n'existait pas avant de façon assez
étonnante en 2012 vous n'aviez aucune
visibilité pour piloter une politique
publique aussi complexe que celle du
logement sur la réalité du prix du
logement et du prix des loyers
territoire par territoire donc d'avoir
une même méthodologie qui pourrait
s'appuyer dans certains cas sur les
départements parce qu'ils ont une
histoire dans d'autres cas et des pactes
très développés dans d'autres cas sur
les régions dans d'autres cas sur les
métropoles mais avec une même
méthodologie qui serait dans son
élaboration qui ferait l'objet dans son
élaboration d'une association des
territoires les associations des
différentes collectivités sont
suffisamment structurées pour pouvoir
être des interlocuteurs je pense valable
je crois que ce sera une bonne chose
mais
la mise en cohérence est quand même très
utile parce que si dans certains cas
notamment en Île-de-France vous
traversez un trottoir vous êtes sur une
commune où vous avez telle étalée de
l'autre côté votre voisin d'en face
parce qu'il se trouve sur une autre
commune en fait ça rien à voir c'est pas
très très compréhensible donc une mise
en cohérence des interventions des
collectivités locales me paraît très une
très bonne chose
merci beaucoup madame la ministre donc
on va passer à des questions donc
première intervenant c'est Frank mangé
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la ministre pour vous votre exposé
par rapport à votre exercice ministériel
vous avez évoqué la relation de travail
avec Philippe Martin qui était à
l'époque ministre de l'écologie dans la
loi de transition énergétique et de
croissance verte qui date de 2015
son article 22 était était prévu des
plateformes territoriales de rénovation
énergétique et tout un tout un
dispositif permettant effectivement sur
les territoires de mettre en place ou de
tenter de mettre en place des guichets
uniques en rapport avec les artisans etc
voilà une rationalisation je dirais de
ce que vous appelez de de vous si j'ai
bon compris dans votre propos est-ce que
ces dispositifs est-ce que vous avez un
regard sur ces dispositifs qui ont été
mis en oeuvre après votre départ du
d'une part et est-ce que
dans votre travail donc jusqu'en 2014
éventuellement en
coopération collaboration avec le
ministère de l'Écologie de l'époque vous
aviez déjà conceptualiser
ce dispositif de guichet unique
opérationnel permettant de répondre très
concrètement très facilement aux besoins
d'information en même temps qu'à la mise
en oeuvre après évaluation voilà de ce
qu'il y avait à faire en matière de
rénovation énergétique merci
pour être raisonnette je n'ai pas de
visibilité de la réalité aujourd'hui
puisque comme vous l'avez rappelé j'ai
fait le choix de ne plus travailler je
pense que c'est bien pour les anciens
ministres au risque d'être gris ou un
peu en conflit d'intérêt donc je suis
plus du tout investi dans ces champs là
mais c'était la déclinaison
opérationnelle de ce que nous avions mis
en place avec Philippe Martin qui
s'appelait les points rénovation info
service qui était un guichet unique
d'informations
450 avaient été créés en s'appuyant sur
ce qui existait les points faux énergie
en utilisant ce qui existait mais en
donnant ce que j'avais dit et donc
l'idée c'était de là c'était un point
d'information et de passer à l'étape
d'après c'est-à-dire un guichet unique
de mise en oeuvre donc je sais pas ce
qu'il en est mais en tout cas je suis
sûr que c'est le bon chemin que il
s'agit pas d'avoir un modèle unique qui
soit en préfecture etc pas du tout il
s'agit en revanche d'avoir une
méthodologie et puis de pouvoir avoir en
revanche un accès unique c'était le clé
de la clé de ce qu'on se lancer un
numéro azur et vous pouviez appeler
n'importe où en fonction de votre
adresse on savait vers où vous renvoyez
c'est à dire que là vous aviez vous
aviez pas justement à faire trois quatre
cinq endroits pour avoir essayé de
collecter les informations des
différents éléments donc je peux pas
vous répondre de façon très précise sur
la mise en œuvre mais je crois que c'est
assez évident que c'est ça qu'il faut
faire en lien avec les entreprises et
notamment les entreprises RGE là aussi
il y avait eu un bon de de l'adhésion
dispositif RGE qui est quand même un pas
intéressant pour créer une sorte de de
task force de réponse au défi
énergétique
et les collectivités parce que les dan
la loi les collectivités étaient
impliquées à travers les ptre qu'elle
pouvait d'ailleurs déléguer un DSP etc
les régions avaient la loi Matane ont
aussi été responsabilisés sur ces
questions-là on est dans un maquis une
complexité y compris entre collectivité
qui interroge aujourd'hui c'est ce que
je dis c'est que chacun veut avoir sa
politique et en faire ça promotion et
surtout veut avoir un dossier de
subvention avec son logo d'ailleurs le
nouveau logo qu'il a créé parce que
l'ancien président avait lui-même créé
un autre logo donc si vous avez un
ancien dossier ça marche plus parce
qu'il faut bien être sûr que c'est la
région et le président ou la présidente
machin qui vous a donné
1275,13 et puis le président de la
collectivité trucmuche qui vous a donné
712,37 et ça c'est pas possible en fait
alors je je pense que peut-être on
pourrait avoir un dossier avec tous les
logos s'ils veulent tous être contents
une lettre où il y a leurs photos et
tous les présidents et les élus si ça
leur plaît mais il faudrait que ce soit
simple du point de vue des utilisateurs
c'est ça la question donc moi je suis
c'est pour ça que je vous le dis avec
autant de franchise mais aussi en
souriant que les collectivités veulent
dire c'est aussi nous qui participons je
trouve ça tout à fait légitime et c'est
vrai qu'elles ont notamment dans un
certain nombre de cas notamment avec les
copropriétés
je pense en particulier au dispositif
parisien par exemple qui a été capable
de pouvoir débloquer quand même un
certain nombre de situations avec un
patrimoine assez ancien très dense très
enclavé très complexe mais à ce titre là
je dis qu'il y a encore des évolutions
législatives qui peuvent être faites sur
les servitudes de cours commune et la
nécessité d'obtenir les autorisations
des copropriétés voisines ça a avancé
mais je pense que alors on vous allez
voir t sans doute à la question du droit
constitutionnel de propriété mais quand
même c'est souvent ça qui est un frein
donc je suis certaine monsieur le
sénateur que c'est la clé parce qu'en
fait vous vous
vous découragez un certain nombre de
gens et il y a des gens qui abandonnent
des projets de rénovation parce qu'ils
ont pas assez de montant de subvention
alors qu'en fait il l'aurait s'il
connaissait les différents possibilités
qui leur seraient qui leur sont de
faites ouvertes donc cette question you
guichet unique elle est évidente et pour
moi absolument décisive et ce d'autant
plus que différents acteurs se sont
mobilisés pour répondre à l'enjeu
merci Laurent saumon
madame la Présidente merci madame la
ministre sur deux choses que vous avez
dites effectivement qui avait le risque
de l'éviction des passoires thermiques
et donc il serait remis à la vente et
qui risquerait de concentré
effectivement les investisseurs et que
est-ce que ça ne s'oppose pas je dirais
aussi par le fait qu'il y ait la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
dispositifs fiscaux type crédits
d'impôts ça s'oppose pas je dirais avec
l'encadrement des loyers qui
naturellement d'un site pas non plus je
dirais des bailleurs privés à faire des
travaux s'ils ne sont pas sûr d'avoir un
retour sur investissement par rapport
aux travaux de rénovation thermique
qu'il ferait ça c'était ma première
question et puis j'ai bien entendu
effectivement qu'il fallait un guichet
unique un diagnostic global une loi de
programmation ça me paraît évident qu'on
n'arrive pas alors qu'on a réussi sur
leur rue enfin de faire une politique
globale sur la rénovation urbaine
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à faire sur la
rénovation sur le logement vous dites
qu'il y a des des incidences politiques
ou personnelles pour autant je dirais
que la modification des lois qui
succèdent
différentes majorité c'est souvent parce
que le constat d'un échec aussi et donc
on essaie de modifier de corriger voire
effectivement de renommer mais et les
collectivités sont dans la même dans le
même dispositif c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
ils accompagnent une politique d'État
parce qu'elle est souvent insuffisante
je pense aux collectivité locale quand
elle le peuvent par exemple les
départements ne peuvent plus parce
qu'ils ont plein la compétence logement
qui était transféré aux EPCI et qu'il
serait peut-être de trouver la trame la
plus efficiente entre l'État une
politique globale et une efficience
locale est-ce que ça n'est pas plutôt
état département parce qu'il a aussi la
responsabilité de la précarité des gens
qui sont en difficulté et donc de
résoudre au travers des charges
justement de trouver des solutions pour
un meilleur logement et une meilleure
cadre de vie voilà un petit peu mais mes
réflexions par rapport à ce que vous
avez dit alors si José je me peut-être
votre commission va permettre de faire
avancer les choses c'est à dire que le
rang hérissement du coup de l'énergie va
quand même avoir je pense que ça a fait
monter au cerveau une préoccupation qui
pouvait apparaître comme un peu reculé
donc peut-être que les choses vont
évoluer je pense pas du tout que ce soit
impossible je le dis et je vous renvoie
au chiffre de de mars 2014 la
mobilisation de cette somme qui c'est
1,2 milliard d'euros c'était pas non
plus c'est pas 150 milliards on est on
est sur des politiques qui sont des
politiques accessibles à montrer que
c'était possible donc je je sais pas
pourquoi ça jamais été fait encore
en tout cas moi c'est c'est comme ça que
je voyais les choses et c'était
justement ce qu'on avait remis en place
on n'avait pas le temps de faire voter
une noix de programmation et puis ça
aurait été très compliqué mais c'était
l'idée l'idée c'était de justement cette
rationalisation comme vous dites mais
surtout cette fluidification c'est plus
le terme que j'emploie c'est à dire
c'est pas grave s'il y a plusieurs
acteurs si c'est fluide le fait
notamment de du fait que vous remplissez
pas 36 dossiers mais que vous remplissez
un dossier et que ensuite il est
transmis aux uns et aux autres est-ce
que ça heurte pas la question
d'encadrement des loyers non parce que
si je pousse votre logique vous pouvez
avoir des loyers élevés plus des charges
très élevées c'est ce qui est en train
de se passer donc la question qui est
posée c'est celle du financement de la
rénovation de ces logements et c'est
pour ça que je pense que plus que les
vendre il faut être dans une logique où
on travaille avec les bailleurs et que
alors même si je sais que en
Île-de-France la société d'économie
mixte dont c'était la mission est en
voie de disparition si je me trompe pas
on peut imaginer des systèmes de portage
à mon avis des systèmes de portage
financiers qui permettent de réaliser
ces travaux pour le compte de tir parce
qu'on pourrait aussi imaginer qu'il y
ait des outils qui soient des outils qui
permettent de faire plusieurs logements
simultanément on a ça plutôt été
efficace ce qui a été fait avec les
copropriétés notamment avec l'ouverture
du prêt à taux zéro ça c'est le résultat
du travail que nous avions fait en 2013
2014 c'est à dire la création de ce prêt
à taux zéro pour les copropriétés c'est
la copropriété qui souscrit auprès
chaque copropriétaire rembourse en
fonction de cette centième et ça
fonctionne à ma connaissance plutôt bien
parce que justement il y a cette
dimension collective qui permet d'éviter
que chaque copropriétaire aille lui-même
à la chasse à un prêt à taux zéro
et donc la question de maintenir un parc
accessible c'est celle du financement de
cette Vaud de rénovation plutôt que
l'augmentation du prix des loyers parce
que si en fait vous dites ok on peut
financer les travaux de rénovation
thermique mais au lieu de payer de
l'électricité vous allez payer plus de
loyer on est déjà à des niveaux de loyer
dont on voit bien qui pèse de manière
extrêmement préoccupante et je pense que
la période que l'on vit va renchérir
cette situation on a énormément augmenté
depuis les années 60 la part consacré au
logement dans les dépenses contraintes
des ménages et notamment des ménages les
plus précaires mais même pas seulement
jusque au troisième quatrième des cils à
la différence des ménages les plus aisés
donc ce poids que pèse aujourd'hui le
logement dans les dépenses contraintes
de mon point de vue ne doit pas être
augmenté et là aussi mais c'est pas du
tout l'objet de votre commission le
bilan de l'encadrement des loyers ça a
été que même une majorité qui n'était
pas la majorité de François Hollande a
remis en place au travers de la loi Elan
cette disposition parce que y compris
les élus locaux ont bien compris la
nécessité de pouvoir utiliser cette
clé-là et je le dis en particulier pour
les petits logements en particulier pour
les studios qui avait fait l'objet eux
de l'augmentation la plus importante du
niveau de loyer
donc je pense qu'il est tout à fait
possible de conduire une véritable
politique de logement qui
poursuit les deux objectifs
simultanément parce que je crois que la
puissance publique est légitime
d'intervenir sur ce dossier et qu'elle
peut créer les outils donc on a mis en
place notamment on a confié à ce qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui
à mince au grand établissement public
francilien bref ça va me revenir la
capacité de pouvoir faire du portage
pour gérer les copropriétés dégradées
parce que et là aussi je le dis et
notamment dans le sud-est de la France
il va y avoir un scénario noir que un
certain nombre de spécialistes avaient
déjà
identifié il y a 10 ans qui est une
nouvelle génération de copropriété
dégradée ces bâtiments des années 70-80
on les propriétaires sont vieillissants
et ne parviennent pas à couvrir le
montant d'entretien notamment beaucoup
qui avait été équipé d'ascenseurs qui
nécessitent des travaux importants etc
donc on va être de la même manière
confronté à une nouvelle vague de
copropriété dégradée et pour faire écho
à ce que vous avez dit je pense qu'il
faudra faire un non-rue des copropriétés
de la même manière qu'on l'a fait pour
le patrimoine du logement social et donc
d'avoir un outil qui a un outil qui en
fait à les rins solide ce que c'est ça
qu'est-ce qui arrive aux propriétaires
privés pour certains d'entre eux ils ont
pas la capacité de des investissements
et si on a si on a d'os et si on
mutualise le risque et le coup de
manière plus large c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus simple et là il existe
déjà des outils que ce soit alors je
suis pas sûr qu'ils portent toujours le
même nom mais ce qui s'appelait les
pactes il y a beaucoup de d'outils qui
existent déjà et qui pourraient être
simplement
diversifier remuscler mobiliser moi je
pense pas qu'il y a besoin d'inventer
mais il y a besoin de d'avoir une
politique globale et tenue dans la durée
la question de la répartition des
compétences entre les différentes
collectivités dont vous a parlé Laurent
saumon par exemple le fait que le
département n'a plus dans ses
compétences le logement mais que son
cœur de métier reste le social enfin etc
comment vous vous verriez éventuellement
les choses
évoluées ou est-ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui tels que l'organisation
territoriale fonctionne ce n'est pas un
frein
supplémentaire madame la Présidente
serait très tenté de répondre à vos
questions sur l'organisation
territoriale de la France sur les
réformes récentes et sur celles qui
semblent être annoncée mais je pense pas
que c'est l'objet de votre commission
donc je vais éviter de de
m'emballer sur ce sujet je pense qu'il
faut faire avec le monde tel qui
existait dans je vais peut-être être là
extrêmement réalo de service mais j'ai
toujours pensé ça dans le cadre de mes
activités politiques si on attend
d'avoir l'organisation territoriale
parfaite avant d'engager la rénovation
énergétique autant vous dire rendez-vous
quand à plus 4 degrés donc je pense
qu'on peut créer de la fluidité et on
l'a montré que on pouvait le faire dans
tout un tas de de politique publique ça
veut dire qu'il faut en fait à la fois
une orientation collective assez ferme
et assez claire pour tout le monde et
ensuite laisser la latitude au
territoire de s'organiser dans un cadre
défini ça veut dire qu'il faut pas dire
voilà vous devez avoir une scène dans
laquelle vous avez
tant de représentant de ça tant de
représentant de ça tant de représentant
de ça en fait on s'en fiche la question
c'est de fixer des objectifs et de dire
voilà quel est le le cadre global et
ensuite de laisser les initiatives se
faire parce que sur certains territoires
et bien le entre le département la
région et l'interco c'est fluide dans
d'autres vous avez une baston homérique
entre la ville et la métropole je ne
cite personne mais voilà et donc si vous
essayez d'abord de les mettre ensemble
avant de faire avancer les choses vous
pouvez y passer un siècle donc je crois
qu'il faut s'adapter à la réalité des
territoires mais il faut qu'il y ait un
cap et des moyens qui pas très clair
alors il y a encore deux interventions
il y a
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre alors je m'intéresse beaucoup
aux questions du patrimoine
architecturales et j'aimerais avoir
votre avis sur la manière dont on
devrait être appréhendé l'isolation du
bâti qui a une valeur patrimoniale et là
je pense au bâti qui n'est pas protégé
comme les fermes les maisons de bourre
de village puisque actuellement seuls
les monuments historiques et les
bâtiments qui sont protégés dans les
documents d'urbanisme font l'objet d'un
traitement spécifique pour le reste du
bâti les calculs et les préconisations
du DPE sont identiques que l'on parle
d'une d'un bâti des trentes glorieuses
ou alors d'une d'une ferme qui a 400 ans
et ce qui conduit aussi à des
isolations inadaptées avec des dégâts
souvent irréversibles je le vois chez
moi en Alsace avec du polystyrène sur du
pan de bois ou alors à des renoncements
et avec des bâtiments qui sont un moment
donné et ensuite détruit dans le cadre
du zan
voilà je vous remercie cette question je
pense qu'à cet instant je vais me faire
à peu près tous les ennemis de la terre
mais pourtant je vais le dire j'ai
énormément
de goûts pour le patrimoine bâti de la
France
parce que du fait de sa diversifier de
sa diversité dont son histoire et je
pense que c'est extrêmement riche et que
je suis aussi une écologie convaincue
qui sait à quel point on a besoin de
faire diminuer nos émissions et donc de
travailler sur l'isolation des bâtiments
et là
et j'ai vu dans un certain nombre de cas
les architectes des bâtiments de France
être extrêmement rétif voir très très
fâché et avec des résultats qui étaient
ce que vous avez dit à la fin c'est à
dire qu'au final en fait on fait plus
rien du tout et du coup on laisse
s'écrouler des bâtiments donc en la
matière ma religion c'est que c'est ni
blanc ni noir c'est gris clair et gris
foncé et qu'il faut réussir c'est pour
ça que je parlais de ce livre certains
bâtiments vous n'arriverez jamais à
aller au BBC mais vous pouvez faire
beaucoup mieux que ce qui existe il y a
aussi une question
aux travaux
avec j'allais dire des matériaux déjà
existants et en lien avec l'entreprise
avec les entreprises avec les laboration
d'un devis alors qu'en fait dans un
certain nombre de cas l'utilisation des
architectes peut être très utile et
c'est pour ça que là il y a des outils
qui peuvent être extrêmement utiles les
parcs naturels régionaux avaient
beaucoup travaillé justement pour donner
des guides en matière de rénovation qui
était laissée à eux évidemment ont
beaucoup travaillé et je pense que là on
a la richesse pour le coup on a les
professionnels et de la même manière que
on pourrait organiser de façon plus
fluide le financement et la mise en
oeuvre de ce financement on pourrait
dire dans telle région avec tel type de
bâtiment sur les briques c'est mieux de
faire comme ça sur les moelleux c'est ça
le pan de bois on peut faire telle et
telle chose mais aujourd'hui ça n'existe
pas je le dis c'est ça n'existe pas
alors que je suis certaine que les
compétences existent mais qu'elles sont
pas du tout mises en oeuvre donc je
refuse en tout cas à titre personnel
qu'on doit faire le choix entre
l'isolation thermique et le patrimoine
je pense qu'il y a plein de solutions et
que oui parfois ça va pas être
suffisamment satisfaisant c'est à dire
que il y a certains bâtiments
l'argument de je sais pas moi de garder
certaines
formes de fenêtres anciennes de garder
des fenêtres à baïonnette bah oui ça va
être plus compliqué mais on pourra faire
l'effort sur ce point là parce qu'on
aura finalement dit que on n'allait pas
garder les combles et qu'on allait
isoler de façon plus intéressante les
combles je donne un exemple comme ça à
froid mais je pense que c'est vraiment
ça qu'il faut creuser et que il faut
redonner et peut-être vous savez dans
l'histoire de France il y a
plein de moments où il y a eu des
architectes de l'État qui ont une grande
réflexion alors ils ont ça aboutit à des
citer et à des constructions aux
constructions des zones d'urbanisation
prioritaires avec plus ou moins de
bonheur mais il y a eu des grandes
réflexions nationales sur ces sujets et
je pense qu'une grande réflexion sur
patrimoine et rénovation
thermique avec des clés avec de vrais
spécialistes avec des exemples à
l'étranger
mais sans crispation des uns ou des
autres en disant en fait les écolos qui
veulent rénover ils détestent le
patrimoine et ils veulent que du bardage
univoque et des fenêtres moches et de
l'autre côté oui mais vous regardez avec
eux on peut même pas mettre un panneau
solaire parce qu'il y a une
éventuellement une semi-8e de
covisibilité avec l'église
Saint-Ambroise qui est
sympathique mais enfin purement 19e et
dont l'intérêt patrimonial est quand
même relativement limité que sur un toit
qui n'est effectivement à moins de 500
mètres mais complètement dans l'autre
sens enfin je pense qu'on peut trouver
des terrains d'entente moi je ne donc
c'est pour ça que je dis je me fais
finalement me fâcher avec tout le monde
mais je suis une écologie très attachée
au patrimoine et notamment au patrimoine
architectural y compris vous avez raison
au petit patrimoine celui qui n'est pas
protégé je sais bien qu'au château de
Versailles et même au Sénat il va rien
lui arriver mais oui il y a certains
certaines rues et certaines façades de
rue à Dieppe par exemple
qui
reflète l'histoire et sur lesquels il
faut travailler de manière intelligente
et c'est on peut pas demander aux
propriétaires eux-mêmes voire aux
copropriétaires d'avoir la capacité de
financer le travail d'un architecte on
n'a pas non plus des milliers de
différence de patrimoine en France et je
pense qu'on pourra avoir une sorte de
cahier et de guide de bonnes pratiques
qui seraient aussi utile auprès des
professionnels et qui pourraient être
intégrés dans le dispositif RGE au-delà
de du type de savoir-faire technique de
la manière de poser une fenêtre on
pourrait aussi y intégrer une dispositif
relatif aux différents patrimoine
architectural du pays
et vous même vous ne vous étiez pas
attelé pendant votre ministère mais
d'autres priorité ou préoccupations
alors madame la Présidente la compétence
comment dire la supervision des
architectes et historiquement confiée au
ministère de la Culture et je pense que
s'il fallait parler en langage purement
ministériel je pense qu'une co-tutelle
j'ai alors certains architectes le
souhaitaient pour être vraiment utile
parce que je suis absolument convaincue
qu'il faut remettre de l'architecture et
du savoir faire architectural dans la
pensée du logement ça peut sembler un
peu tomber sur le sens mais mais c'est
le cas et valoriser tous ces jeunes
architectes qui sont beaucoup plus
modestes que un certain nombre de leurs
énigmes à qui on avait élevé dans cette
culture là et qui trouve sa valorisant
de pouvoir
rénover un bâtiment en brique de la fin
du 19e
alors amalgaquer et puis Michel Dagbert
et puis après on libérera madame la
ministre je vais donc être très bref
merci madame la ministre je voudrais
juste revenir donc assez rapidement sur
la limite ou plutôt une réflexion avec
sur laquelle je suis assez d'accord avec
vous sur la nécessité d'avoir une
approche globale en termes de logement à
la limite de poser sur la table des
dispositifs qui en fait créé parfois des
effets véritablement pervers et pour ça
je vais prendre pour exemple la fameuse
disposition qui a été évoquée tout à
l'heure sur l'obligation de ne plus
mettre sur le marché à partir de 2025
les logements et qui en fait va avoir
comme effet de restreindre davantage par
exemple le nombre de logements sur le
marché locatif la question est très
simple et très ciblée en tout cas sur ce
sujet là compte tenu des conséquences
que cela peut avoir ne faudrait-il pas
par exemple revoir l'échéancier sur
cette disposition là puisque là la
question n'est pas juste financière
n'est pas juste économique il y a
d'autres questions qui se posent qui ne
sont c'est pas les mêmes que celles que
vous avez rencontrées il y a 10 ans on a
aujourd'hui aussi en termes de matériaux
en termes de main d'oeuvre des
particularités des difficultés que nous
l'avions peut-être pas il y a 10 ans ça
c'est ma première question qu'il a
deuxième mais très rapide et demain si
on vous parce que vous avez entendu dire
que vous aviez quitté la sphère
politique mais vous êtes encore très ça
un discours en tout cas encore très très
engagé je n'en suis pas surprise je
crois que si demain nous on l'a toujours
mais si demain on devait vous donner ce
ministère quel budget vous demanderiez
avec quel objectif que les choses enfin
bref si c'était à refaire que
feriez-vous mais voilà une réponse très
brève quelle est votre vision des choses
là-dessus merci alors sur le risque
d'éviction il est réel mais je pense que
aujourd'hui le risque d'éviction il
s'est surtout fait au profit du logement
type Airbnb beaucoup plus que voilà et
donc je pense que la la régulation de ce
de la manière dont on
n'utilise le patrimoine bâti je le
rappelle 80% des logements dans lesquels
on vivra en 2050 sont déjà construits
donc on travaille sur ce qui existe et
la question c'est avoir ce qu'on en fait
les logements ça a cette particularité
que ça se délocalise pas en Suisse même
quand ça subit l'encadrement des loyers
et que ça ne se construit pas comme ça
par génération spontanée donc il faut
faire avec le patrimoine tel qu'il
existe la position vous dites était je
me souviens avoir une discussion avec la
Fondation Abbé Pierre à ce sujet mais au
vu du poids et du risque finalement de
laisser les personnes les plus précaires
dans ce type de logement tout le monde
est résolu au fait que il faut rénover
ces bâtiments et ce patrimoine
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut faire sortir les
logements de la précarité énergétique la
question n'est plus de savoir est-ce que
on exclut c'est qu'il faut trouver une
solution alors que cette solution se
fasse par des particuliers qui achètent
moins cher parce que on assiste quand
même une baisse du fait du prix ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on voit bien
qu'on qu'on internalise finalement le
coût de la rénovation ensuite sur la
question des techniques là je sais pas à
quoi vous faites référence donc je
ne peut pas vous répondre et pour vous
dire quel serait mon programme général
en tant que
néo-minis du logement je vous avoue que
j'étais venu pour vous rendre compte sur
ce que j'ai fait il y a 10 ans donc je
suis pas tout à fait préparé mais en
tout cas en la matière je il y a des
choses sur lesquelles je pourrais dire
que je ferai différemment en la matière
on avait bien fait il y avait un seul
numéro de téléphone
les gens ils disaient ah bah tiens
est-ce qu'on peut faire quelque chose on
leur on leur répondait on les envoyait
vers les bonnes personnes et on essayait
de leur dire voilà vu votre situation
financière vous avez droit à ça ce qui
est en fait pas un truc très intelligent
ça nécessitait pas un génie politique
pour faire ça c'est juste de se mettre
aussi à la place des gens et puis
d'avoir constaté pourquoi ça marchait
pas
tout simplement donc et sur la question
des moyens je pense que quelques
milliards d'euros je dis quelques
milliards oui non mais pardon mais vous
savez en Allemagne l'année dernière pour
faire baisser le prix du carburant on a
dépensé 100 milliards d'euros je sais
que et puis en plus je sais que dans ce
pays finalement on arrive plus
facilement à mobiliser quelques
milliards d'euros que quelques millions
voilà donc ce que m'a appris cette
expérience
gouvernementale c'est qu'il va oui oui
le plan le programme investissement
d'avenir il y avait 500 millions il y
avait des milliards enfin tout d'un coup
on les a trouvés et par ailleurs je le
dis ça c'est de l'argent et j'aimerais
bien qu'on fasse cet exercice qui est de
l'argent qui rapporte à l'état c'est à
dire que ça n'est pas un don c'est un
investissement sans compter les coûts
induits considérables que
va provoquer le changement climatique
quand on a mon engagement je vous
remercie je peux vous assurer qu'il ne
va pas faiblir
bon bah c'est tout alors merci madame la
Présidente merci Madame la Ministre
merci surtout pour la liberté de temps
qui est la vôtre mais qui me rend
service parce que
j'ai bonne mémoire puisque j'avais gardé
de vous selon moi très rapidement je
vais pas revenir sur mes jeux souscris
pleinement à ce que mon collègue
Laurence saumon a dit sur les
compétences notamment au niveau
départemental puisque tant que président
de département j'ai le souvenir quand
même que le
la part des solidarités humaines des
politiques sociales et prégnantes dans
l'activité des départements et ça ne me
semblait pas absurde que de pouvoir
conserver cette compétence en matière de
logement ne l'ayant plus il n'empêche
que j'insiste sur un point j'ai bien
compris que vous ne vouliez pas parler
de
revisite des échelons territoriaux des
politiques publiques etc
non non mais il n'en demeure pas moins
qu'il existe d'ores et déjà un outil qui
s'appelle appelle la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique et je
souscris pleinement au fait que vous
disiez il faut toujours qu'on mette son
nom le logo etc je pense que c'est au
sein de la conférence territoriale de
l'action publique que ces arbitrages-là
doivent se rendre et qu'on doit faire
pour le citoyen faire en sorte que ces
politiques soient lisibles et accessible
et c'est en ça que le numéro unique
m'apparaissait comme étant vraiment ce à
quoi il faut revenir voilà donc il y a
pas de question j'abandonne mes
souscrits à ce qui a été dit par mon
collègue
très intéressant et vraiment vous nous
avez donné de
un beau bilan et de des pistes de
réflexion qui me semblent voilà être
susceptible d'être poursuivant creusé en
tout cas merci beaucoup merci bonne fin
de journée à vous merci beaucoup et je
lirai avec intérêt vos travaux en tout
cas vous ce sujet est un sujet
absolument essentiel je le redis devant
vous trois sources d'émissions gaz à
effet de serre le bâtiment l'agriculture
et les transports donc s'il faut
prioriser ça fait partie des priorités
donc on rendra nos travaux fin juin à
peu près et je vous applaudirai
personnellement le jour du vote d'une
grande loi de programmation